Few occupations from history are as maligned
as that of Medieval-era executioner.
Popularly painted as gleeful dispensers of
death and torture, the truth seems to be that
many executioners throughout this period usually
treated the occupation with a certain reverence
and exhibited an extreme dedication to duty.
Beyond trying to minimize the suffering of
those slated to be executed, this was, among
other reasons we’ll get into, because it
would often mean the life of the executioner
if they ever botched an execution or otherwise
weren’t extremely professional in carrying
out their job.
So, moving beyond any Hollywood depictions,
what was it actually like to be an executioner
in the ballpark of Medieval times and how
did someone get the job in the first place?
A thing to note before we continue is that
the duties expected of and performed by executioners,
as well as what life was like for specific
executioners, has varied wildly across time
and regions.
For example, as we’ve talked before, those
condemned to death in the Ottoman empire during
the 18th century could potentially get off
scot-free by challenging the executioner to
a footrace.
In this case, in addition to doling out lethal
justice with their bare hands, executioners
also worked as both bodyguards and gardeners.
That caveat out of the way, how did one become
an executioner in the first place?
It turns out that many European Medieval executioners
were former criminals themselves.
You see, for reasons we’ll get into shortly,
the role of executioner was so unpopular that
finding someone to do the job often required
either forcing someone into the profession
or offering the gig to someone who was slated
to be executed themselves.
Scandinavian countries were known to make
extensive use of this novel hiring practice,
with a little twist thrown in- they’d maim
executioners by cutting off one or both of
their ears so that they could be easily identified
by the public.
It also wasn’t uncommon for people made
executioners in this way to be branded somewhere
on their head, once again for the purpose
of their new profession being, in this case
literally, written all over their face.
For example, as noted in Hugo Mathiessen’s
Boddel og Galgefugl,
In the year 1470, a poor thief stood at the
foot of the gallows in the Swedish town Arboga
and was waiting to be hanged.
The public attending the spectacle had pity
on the sinner and when he, to save his neck,
offered to become executioner in the town,
it was agreed.
He was pardoned and the red-hot iron was used
to brand his body with both thief and executioner
mark.
In Germany, on the other hand, as author Joel
Harrington notes in a discussion of his book,
The Faithful Executioner: Life and Death,
Honor and Shame in the Turbulent Sixteenth
Century, while “standing executioners on
salary were the norm” throughout Germany
during the 1600s, for many centuries prior
to this it was commonplace to thrust role
of executioner upon a victim’s oldest male
relative.
This all brings us around to why so many avoided
the profession like the plague.
To begin with, the general consensus among
most was that in taking such a job, one was
then sure to be damned in the afterlife.
This was despite the fact that in some regions,
such as France, executioners were by official
church decree absolved of the sins committed
while performing their duties.
This still didn’t stop the general public
from considering executioners unclean, leading
to the more practical problem with the job-
nearly being completely ostracized from society.
Coming back to those condemned to die instead
becoming an executioner, people seem to have
been perfectly fine with this as the criminal’s
life would still be forfeit, just in a more
metaphorical sense.
For example, throughout Medieval Europe executioners
were often forced to live in houses outside
of the city or town they plied their trade
in.
In cases where this wasn’t possible, they
tended to live near things like public latrines,
lepertoriums, or brothels.
Executioners were similarly often denied citizenship
to the towns and cities they served (and thus
had few rights in the town) and were largely
barred from holding office or even entering
churches, pubs, bathhouses, etc- basically
most public establishments were off limits
to the executioner.
Thus, despite executioners being deemed critical
for a society to remain civilised, they were
paradoxically generally forced to live apart
from that civilised society.
In fact, some places across Europe went as
far to institute laws specifically targeting
executioners and what they could and could
not do in their day to day lives.
For example, the Bavarian town of Memmingen
enacted an ordinance in 1528 that forbade
members of the general public dining with
an executioner.
Such laws and just general attitudes effectively
limited the people an executioner could interact
with in their day to day lives to their own
family and those from the criminal underworld
who simply didn’t care that the executioner
was unclean.
On top of this, an executioner’s children
and spouse were likewise similarly shunned
by anyone but the underbelly of society.
This, combined with the fact that the children
of executioners could usually only find mates
with children of other executioners, understandably
led to the role of executioner becoming a
macabre family trade that resulted in executioner
dynasties that spanned centuries.
Beyond being ostrosised and damning your progeny
to a similar life, as well as an afterlife
full of hellfire, while there were potentially
ways for an executioner to make a killing
within the profession, it turns out for most
there simply weren’t enough executions themselves
to make ends meet.
Alternate work was limited to jobs nobody
else wanted.
This included all manner of things, from disposal
of corpses (animal and human), emptying cesspools,
collecting taxes from the diseased and prostitutes,
etc.
Oddly, at least from a modern perspective,
another common profession for a well trained
executioner was that of a doctor and surgeon.
You see, beyond executing people, another
thing executioners were often called to do
was torture people for various reasons.
These two things, combined with the close-knit
community of executioners sharing their knowledge
amongst themselves, resulted in lifelong executioners
generally having exceptional knowledge of
human anatomy, and thus they were commonly
called on to treat various medical maladies.
In fact, one rather famous 17th century German
executioner, Frantz Schmidt, noted in his
journal that over the course of his near five
decade career he had over 15,000 people he
treated as a doctor, while executing only
394 and disfiguring or otherwise torturing
or flogging roughly the same number- meaning
most of the time he functioned as a doctor,
despite society at the time considering him
an executioner.
Schmidt was one of those thrust into the profession
as his father was strong-armed into becoming
an executioner, condemning Schmidt to the
same life once he came of age, though Schmidt’s
story has something of a happy ending.
Like many executioners, Schmidt was given
a wide berth by the public in his day-to-day
life, but the incredible professionalism with
which he conducted his grisly duties earned
him the begrudging respect of both the general
public and those in power.
In his later years, Schmidt was able to parlay
this into a meeting with Nuremberg authorities
and then was able to appeal to Emperor Ferdinand
II himself, with the goal of restoring his
family honor.
Swayed by not just Schmidt’s words, but
also letters from city council members and
other notable people extolling Schmidt’s
character and dedication to his duty, the
then 70 year old executioner was granted both
Nuremberg citizenship and had his family name
cleared, allowing his progeny to escape the
bloody spectre of his work.
Of course, being ultra-professional with the
profession was something of a necessity for
Schmidt as, at the time in Germany, there
was a law stipulating that any executioner
tasked with doling out death by the sword
(a form of execution largely reserved for
especially important individuals) who took
more than three swings to behead a victim
would be condemned to die themselves.
Even where such laws didn’t exist, the job
of an executioner was extremely dangerous
as executioners were also at risk of being
killed either by vengeful relatives or the
crowd witnessing an execution.
In regards to the latter, if an executioner
was especially cruel in their meting out of
punishment, simply incompetent to the point
that they caused undue suffering, or just
otherwise acted in an unprofessional manner
in performing their duties, it wasn’t unheard
of for a crowd to retaliate by killing the
executioner on the spot, generally with no
consequence to anyone in the mob.
This constant danger of the job was something
Schmidt himself talked about several times
in his journal, though he only notes one instance
where the crowd turned into a mob.
This occurred during a flogging he was performing,
with the person being beaten ultimately stoned
to death by the crowd.
As you might imagine from this, in cases like
Schmidt who was trained from childhood to
take over the job from his father, a rather
lengthy apprenticeship was called for, including
a robust education from one’s parent, followed
by assisting in executions and torture from
a young age.
Schmidt also notes that he practiced executions
extensively on various animals before being
allowed to actually execute a human himself.
The end goal of all of this was to make sure
he wouldn’t screw up, as raucous mobs didn’t
really care if it was someone’s first day
on the job or not.
Now, although being an executioner came with
some massive downsides, it wasn’t all bad.
Enterprising executioners could actually earn
a fairly decent living doling out torture
and capital punishment on command if they
were smart about it.
For example, especially skilled executioners
who didn’t mind traveling could take advantage
of the scarcity of people willing to do their
job by plying their trade across whichever
country they happened to live in, rather than
just staying local.
Executioners also frequently earned extra
money in the form of bribes from the condemned
or their families, invariably given in the
hopes that the executioner would ensure death
was as swift and painless as possible, or
otherwise allow the condemned extra comforts
leading up to the execution.
This might include, for example, slipping
them extra alcohol or the like to make the
execution a little easier to handle.
On top of this, throughout much of Medieval
Europe a perk of being an executioner is that
it was customary for whatever property was
worn at the time of death to be granted to
the executioner.
Additionally, executioners in Germany were
frequently tasked with things like arbitrating
disputes between prostitutes and driving lepers
out of town, among other such jobs, all of
which they could charge a premium for because
nobody else was willing to do the job.
Executioners were also sometimes not just
given the job of disposing of animal carcasses,
but also in some regions the explicit right
to all stray animal carcasses found in a town.
Depending on the animal, this could mean the
rights to valuable hides, teeth, etc.
An even greater benefit for certain executioners,
this time in France, was the idea of droit
de havage.
In a nutshell, because executioners were so
ostracized and couldn’t in some regions,
for example, just go down to the market and
shop freely, under droit de havage, executioners
were more or less allowed to tax those who
sold various food and drink items.
This came in the form of being able to demand
goods for free.
Finally, there’s the money an executioner
would be paid for performing an execution,
flogging, or the like.
Although it’s hard to say exactly how much
an executioner could earn per hanging or beheading
in today’s currency due to the inherent
difficulty of gauging the value of historic
currencies, it’s evident that it was a good
amount, at least relative to the generally
low social standing of executioners.
For example, according to information gleaned
from an old statute dated to a small German
town in 1276 an executioner could earn the
equivalent of 5 shillings per execution.
This is an amount roughly equal to the amount
of money a skilled tradesmen could earn in
about 25 days at the time.
Likewise, an executioner operating in England
some two centuries later in the 1400s could
reportedly earn a fee of 10 shillings per
execution, or roughly 16 times the amount
a skilled tradesmen could earn in a single
day.
Granted, as you might have deduced from the
aforementioned case of Frantz Schmidt only
executing about 400 people and flogging a
similar number in his near five decades on
the job, nobody was getting rich doing this
by itself, it at least wasn’t bad pay per
hour of work.
Finally, we’d be remiss in any discussion
of Medieval executioners to not point out
that the idea of executioners wearing masks
to hide who they were does not appear to have
actually been much of a thing.
Beyond, as mentioned, in many regions being
literally branded as executioners, even large
cities for much of history weren’t actually
that large; so people knew who the executioner
in a given region was, if not directly, by
being marked such.
Thus, wearing a mask would have been pointless.